les chéris j'ai d'autres choses la
punchline du week-end alors la punchline
du week-end c'est bien sûr mon ami je
dis c'est mon ami senna pilat c'était le
portrait de la semaine dans 50 minutes
inside
nabila a fait une sortie il ya quelque
peu la faire et c'est pour ça qu'on les
aime regarder quand 46 peut-être bouger
les mêmes initiales que napoléon
bonaparte
attention à à moi peut-être que je suis
sa petite fille on ne sait pas à
vérifier autour d'eux ça c'est
magnifique et oui napoléon bonaparte
nabila et nabila s'est également confié
sur la télé réalité elle a notamment
expliqué que s'il avait réussi à ne pas
vrille et c'est grâce notamment à l'aide
de thomas que j'embrasse au tir ya le
temps et elle peut venir très vite on
l'a vu avec d'autres personnes de la
télé a certes et c'était de faire des
ravages
- qu'est-ce qui vous avoue permis de ne
pas vous perdre en chemin je pense sur
ce point là c'est vraiment mon mari qui
m'a qui m'a aidé mais en quoi vous avez
des bantous le fait de me faire devenir
une femme de m'aider à faire les bons
choix et il me protège en fait de toutes
ces mauvaises fréquentations de toutes
ces personnes qui vont résoudre la toile
à toutes ces choses c'est un roc et là
il me protège et carré il est juste par
ici bon il est très timide
je les adore taillon mais si oui à moi
je les adore je trouve je les suis un
petit peu tous sur les réseaux sociaux
est vraiment je trouve que c'est pas du
tout un couple bancal i-stem depuis des
années ils sont toujours avec leur fils
mylan et ce sondage il était là lui
aussi est vraiment j'adore ce couple est
effectivement là la tête sur les épaules
depuis qu'elle est avec lui elle a
changé
alors osez parler de mylan et c'était là
ses concerts motion émotion que 50
minutes inside regard des parties après
trois jours de travail
la jeune femme donne enfin naissance à
un petit garçon
nilan le moment le plus fort de sa vie
[Musique]
non c'est la naissance de mon fils en
fait je suis très un petit arbre c'est
de la joie
oui non c'est de la joie mais c'est vrai
que j'avais tellement peur de de ce qui
allait m'arriver à ce moment là j'étais
pétrifiée je me suis dit comment je vais
faire je vais devoir m'occuper d'un
petit bébé quand il a fallu aller à la
maternité pour redonner la vie à mon
fils je pensais que j'étais pas prêtes
mais ça s'est bien passé quoi elle
serait à londres du deuxième
ouais c'est vrai oui elle va se marier
d'ailleurs bientôt nabil karoui 6 4 6 4
une merveilleux dans des centres où j'ai
vécu avec ma mamma deuxième femme celle
à qui j'ai eu ma fille qui pensait pas
du tout n'allait pas du tout être une
bonne mère qui était pas du tout prête
pour la maternité puis de 26 ans côté
garçon manqué et du moment de la
naissance s'est transformé les femmes se
transformation c'est quelque chose de
presque magique si ça fait un bon match
et vous dire benjamin et il avait fait
la même chose
il s'est même fait pousser des salles
étaient là